all right uh welcome back and they call
him king henry
for a reason
check out the throne chris sims i'm
gonna go find me one of those and get i
don't think i'm worthy you don't deserve
derek henry is derek henry great to see
you awesome throne how's everything
thank y'all for having me appreciate it
everything's good as you can see
everything's going good
oh everything's going real good 2 000
rushing yards this season
congratulations on that i mean i know
the season didn't end the way you wanted
it to
but you got to be proud of the fact that
you joined a very short list of guys who
cracked the 2000 yard barrier in one
season
yeah
it was very cool um something so surreal
but it made it more cool
is my teammates you know
wanted it even more and uh they're
pushing forward
and trying to do anything they can to
help me get it so
that's really the cool thing about it is
being able to uh
share them all with them which is so
special and i'll be able to have those
memories for my teammates
when you get to 2000 rushing yards i
don't know what the etiquette is do the
other guys who have 2000 rushing yard
seasons do they reach out to you and say
you know welcome to the club uh you know
you're the latest member
yeah that was another thing that was
cool i mean really all of them reached
out
and um you know that's just something
that you know
that was just like so surreal you know
guys in this group you grew up watching
guys who were kind of like the guys who
are your idols kind of like your
heroes and to to be able to put your
name
you know in that group that so unique
group
it's just so cool and very thankful
yeah it's amazing it really is i mean
hey you're you're awesome man i just
want to say that right off the bat
you're a lot of fun to watch i mean holy
cow uh i i am amazed and i just want to
like kind of go along that that line
there of
you know how does your how do you tell
me the difference between a game where
you get 20 carries in a game where you
get 35 carries how much more sore and
beat up are you on a monday after a
heavy workload like that
um
really uh
it's really not that much of a
difference and i know people probably
like yeah you know whatever but really
my body doesn't
don't really feel that bad um you know i
do i do a lot of things to take care of
my body um you know right after the game
going into that
that next week
and um you know my body really doesn't
mean it really doesn't get that sore
you might get a little sore you know i
didn't have scratch a little bump and
bruises but
i was i mean really my body feels good
and you know i don't really feel that
well okay
you're a freaking nature i mean there's
no other way to say it i mean you just
you're you're the king you're on the
throne that's why but okay that's where
the next where i want to go is just what
do you what do you do during the week
during the season to take care of your
body you know i've seen your off-season
training regimens do you train
aggressively too during the season as
well
well they're really just doing the
things take care of my body like massage
needling and you know all those things
cold tub
hot tub and then and then working out
and just doing the things that work um
and uh you know continue to do those
things you know if it's
making me and i get getting ready week
after week to
perform at a high level then just i just
keep doing those things and that's
that's all i really do and it's been
working it's been helping and uh you
know everybody knows offseason but try
to train as much as i can and get
stronger and faster well that's where
that's where i just one more quick one
mike i'm sorry just to follow up we were
just like
i know that i've been with running backs
who you know lift heavy weights on
tuesday wednesday and thursday during
the week during the season i've been
with other ones who just go i don't
really want to lift much weights during
the season how where do you fall in that
line
well i mean i want to say lifting like a
ton of weight but i definitely look
weights during the season um
uh probably three times three times out
the week um i just love to work out so
that's just that's just me i know guys
are different don't really like lift
weights during the season rather not do
that but i mean i mean that's just i
mean i love working out so i don't work
out i kind of feel small so yeah
hey the final number for you for the
season was 2027. that was 78 yards away
from catching eric dickerson for the
single season record i don't know if
you're aware of this
but eric was extremely nervous that your
week 17 game was going to go to overtime
and you were going to break his record
did you hear from him and are you aware
that he was getting a little a little
sweaty a little concerned that the
record was going to go down and you were
going to take it from him
um i actually didn't uh
hear from him but um
i seen that he uh said something about
me uh reaching 2000 which i definitely
appreciated somebody that uh i looked up
to um as i got older and realized my
size and
you know uh my style of play
but um but i didn't know that uh he was
nervous um i really didn't think i was
really gonna get two thousand yards even
even even come close to you know
breaking his record uh definitely a
couple runs in that game that i like to
have back but at the end of the day i
was just happy to be able to eclipse 2
000 you know
and be able to have over my teammates
you average 5.4 yards per carry for the
entire season which is incredibly
impressive given the number of times you
ran the football how did the blocking
change how did the offensive line change
once taylor lawan went down because it
felt like it took a little while for the
offense to kind of get its its footing
back after losing him
yeah i mean it was it was a big blow
because he's really important to what we
do and the energy he brings and the
enthusiasm he brings to our team you
know it's a match but uh um ty uh he
stepped in and did a great job um
throughout camp you know he was playing
and preparing um like he was a starter
and he did a great job stepping into
taylor and then he went down and then uh
quisenberry had to come and take over
but she did a great job as well
so it really really we just picked up
where we left off you know we had a
little bit of adversity a little punch
in the road you know
uh one throughout the season but when we
got rolling uh things started clicking
you know we started to uh you know move
forward and um you know make plays a lot
of plays
well i mean i see those big damn biceps
and triceps you got there so we might as
well talk about your stiff arm this year
i just feel like you know i've seen you
do it in years past but i feel like in
the last year and a half i've seen it
more you know what what has led to that
or what do you do to try to add that to
your game is there is there a concerted
effort to do it
yeah well it's something i've always
done as a kid it's always been uh i
haven't always had no biceps and triceps
and all that i was a long
uh lengthy skinny kid and i was always
you know just just tall so i always use
my stiff arm when i play a little league
and play pop warner and um as i got
older just it always came naturally
something that i always use like you
said in the beginning
of my career
it wasn't as
effective as it was um as it is now so i
took i took it kind of personally if i'm
gonna step forward then
i gotta
i gotta make it be a business decision
for the defenders and that's what i
always try to do
oh it it's unbelievable
yeah it's it's it's
it's awesome man it really is i mean i i
i know josh norman i'm friends with him
he's a good guy i'm gonna definitely
bust on his butt the next time i see him
i can promise you that
um i do want to ask you a little bit you
know because i know you didn't get to
play the bucks but you played the chiefs
last year in the afc championship game
like leading up to the super bowl tell
us some things that jump out to you
about the chiefs defense and what makes
them kind of you know so good but they
kind of fly under the radar
they're clutch
and we all know in this league and in
football
defense winning championships i mean you
can say
they found on the radar but
that's three years in a row they've been
to the nfc championship
and i mean that that's that's that's the
proof right there but when it's time to
make plays in crunch time when the
pressure's on they do that so
i mean
i think what what what what they've been
doing you know the speech for themselves
no matter what you want to say about the
defense they've been pushed and been
helping them get to where they are in
the last couple years now
derek one of the realities of being a
successful team is other teams are going
to start looking at your coaching staff
arthur smith the offensive coordinator
now gone what kind of changes are you
anticipating
after you know losing a guy who did such
a great job putting everything together
for you the past few years
yeah uh love bart um
i think he's gonna have uh
a great career uh as head coach with the
atlanta falcons and do great things over
there
in atlanta you know we know we're
definitely gonna miss him but i don't
think nothing
much is
nothing's gonna change uh too much as
far as what we do i think we are who we
are
i think uh td todd uh come in and you
know take over and you know continue
what we what we've been doing and keep
things rolling but as far as our
identity and how we want to play them
together at all
if julio jones were to call you up and
say tell me what i need to know about
arthur smith since he's now my head
coach what would you tell him
uh get his mind right
you know because art gonna bring it
every day i'm gonna expect you to bring
it every day this is how he is type of
coach he is type of prayer he
um have a growth mindset from ready to
work
all right well all right i gotta i got
one or two more questions for you i know
we're going to talk about old spice too
and how they've made you the king of the
world here but i do want to know
you know
everybody sees you and goes holy crap i
can't believe that's a running back and
how big he is who in the nfl do you walk
on the field with every now and then and
go
holy crap like i can't believe how big
he is or anybody impress you that way
i would say
coles campbell is a big dude
yeah that was a big dude
right
it was huge i've been planning on
playing against them uh for a couple of
years now and i still trying to be like
and that's a big deal
it's it's shocking it really is all
right why do you uh tell us about like
what you're doing with old spice today
big guy
yeah uh it's been a tough year for
everyone
you know we can always use we can all
use that sparkling confidence you know
like like starting your day
with old spice dynasty
uh cologne uh quality scent deodorant
so you can uh
so you can smell ready for anything
and now you know uh
the cologne has a great scent
and uh
it's a great a great a great deodorant
that uh most likes to come out with for
you know everyone to use
to have the the confidence to start your
day
and to be able to get through the tough
year
hey derek we had emmitt smith on the
program yesterday he holds the all-time
career rushing record as you surely know
we asked him who he's watching out there
that may have a chance at some point to
break the record you're the name that he
mentioned does that ever cross your mind
of having the kind of longevity that
would put you up in that stratosphere
with the kind of yardage that emmett
smith has
yeah emma smith
is a legend of florida legend
um
and
for me
i don't see nobody breaking that record
i definitely appreciate you know him
saying that
and um but i don't think i don't see
nobody breaking that record
but uh i'm definitely gonna
try
while while um while i'm here so
you're a worker oh sorry mike my bad man
i was gonna ask this quick follow do you
have an idea in mind as to how long you
want to play
um
i think i'm just going to keep playing
until
you know my body tells me
no that
it's time to hang him up
but um you know hopefully i can play
as long as
you know i don't i don't even know uh i
love this game and i want to play as
long as i can
you're always like self-analyzing
yourself i i appreciate that like i
heard you a few years ago talk about
eddie george right and talking about you
gotta run harder and like okay 2021
season what's derek henry going to be
working on that he didn't like about
2020
yeah i think i'm always working on
everything i think always can be better
i think um you know you can always
improve
no matter how good or how bad just um
you know just focus on being better and
determined to
to to do more and be better and that's
all that's what i'm always going to be
focused on year after year being better
than the year before
and definitely motivated for 2021 and
been working and continue to continue to
work and be ready whenever it's time to
get back for a season hey derek
congratulations on everything you've
accomplished congratulations on having
that kick ass thrown and uh we'll talk
to you soon
all right thank you all for having me
y'all take care you too see you king
henry
see y'all
see you buddy that was great good
talking to you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports